batman's secret identity is the most
closely guarded secret in the dc
universe no one must ever know
well except alfred of course and all the
robins and batgirl and superman and the
justice league
and probably commissioner gordon no
valenzuela except for raz al-ghul
and talia and catwoman push dr hurt well
you get the idea
beyond them however no one must ever
know which is why bruce wayne has got
into some pretty strange extremes
in order to keep people from figuring
out how he spends us nights
here are some truly bizarre ways that
batman has kept his identity
a secret the bodyguard gotham city is a
pretty dangerous town and if you're one
of its high-profile billionaires you're
bound to wind up as a target sooner or
later
that's why the wayne industries board of
directors decided to hire a bodyguard
for the ceo
sacha bordeaux made her first appearance
in detective comics issue 751
taking the job as working as a bodyguard
for the last person in the world
who actually needed one at first bruce
played up his disguise as a flaky
socialite
in an attempt to make sasha so
frustrated that she'd quit
but once she discovered her secret
identity everything changed
since she was still dedicated to
protecting him she insisted on joining
him on his missions as batman
and he decided to train her as a
sidekick with a mask and costume of her
own
despite the fact that she performed
pretty admirably in the role
her tenure ended disastrously when bruce
wayne was framed for murder
and she was arrested as an accessory she
was seemingly killed in prison and then
wound up as a cybernetic superspy
working for an intelligence agency
called checkmates you know you've got a
weird resume when batman's bodyguard
isn't the strangest thing on it
batman incorporated the thing about
batman's secret identity is that it's
not actually that hard to figure out
since everyone already knows that he
drives around gotham city in a
rocket-powered supercar
once you have that it's pretty easy to
connect it to the local billionaire
whose parents were murdered in front of
him as a child
in 2010 however bruce wayne used all
those obvious connections to his
advantage
rather than revealing himself as batman
he instead announced that he'd been the
one financing the caped crusader
using his vast personal fortune to
provide gotham's resident vigilante with
all the grappling hooks batarangs and
batmobiles he needs
and technically that's true even if it
leaves out one pretty important detail
evil twin after batman appeared to die
in the pages of final crisis
dick grayson took over the role but that
left the question of what to do about
batman and bruce wayne
dying at the same time fortunately they
had doctor tommy elliot better known as
a supervillain
hush see elliot was so obsessed with his
childhood friend
bruce wayne that he ended up performing
plastic surgery on his own face
in order to turn himself into wayne's
exact double with batman gone he was
running around pretending to be bruce
wayne
depleting the wayne fortune as fast as
he could to solve the problem batman's
allies decided to let him keep
up the ruse recruiting a massive roster
of other superheroes posed as employees
and assistants
to keep him in line long enough for the
real batman to return from a trip
through the time stream
king batman the first okay this is when
things start to get weird
back in the 50s batman and robin found
themselves transported through a random
time warp to the planet plexius where
batman was amassed when he accidentally
became
king initially batman figured out that
there was no harm in revealing his
identity to an alien world but the
criminal he and robin had been chasing
when they got hit with the time warp was
also there
and more than willing to spill the beans
when he got back to earth while this
entire problem could be avoided by just
leaving the criminal back on plexius to
face interdimensional space justice
that's a little too far from due process
even for batman
instead batman and robin decided that
the best way to protect their identities
was to jump
right back into another random time warp
which fortunately wiped everyone's
memories of the entire story
funny how that works about ventriloquism
batman has done a lot of weird things to
protect a secret but the climax of the
conquest of batman's identity
might be the wildest of all it starts
when detective novelist jj jason
tries to find a bit of inspiration by
solving the most challenging mystery
he can think of figuring out who's
behind batman's mask he studies
footprints analyzes a piece of batman's
cape
and even gathers up a soil sample from
the bat cave to conclusively prove that
batman is bruce wayne
when he confronts bruce about it though
the result isn't what he expects it's
not what anyone expects
like several other stories like this
batman relies on a stand-in wearing his
costume to throw people off the track
superman's done it a few times for
instance and robin has a special costume
of built-in stilts just for such an
occasion
even alfred did it once although for
obvious reasons that usually only works
from a distance
this time though a stand-in batman is
blind and deaf and speaks to jason via
batman using ventriloquism the fake
batman also completely unnamed is never
ever mentioned again literally nothing
at the climax of 2002's hush it's
revealed that tommy elliot wasn't
working alone
instead the real foe behind the
complicated plot that involved almost
every major batman villain was the
riddler who had finally figured out
batman's secret identity
considering that the riddler is one of
batman's more enjoying foes this seems
like a pretty big deal
in that same issue however batman
convinces him not to tell anyone
arguing that riddles are worthless if
everyone knows the answer
of course that conveniently ignores the
fact that it's also pretty worthless to
solve a riddle when nobody else knows
you've done it but eventually it all
worked out
before too long the riddler completely
forgot batman's identity thanks to a
sharp blow to the head and a bout of
amnesia
which might be batman's true superpower
the unstoppable power of coincidence